you're tired cuz the Academy Awards
ended about half an hour ago they were
long long Academy Awards a big big story
of course was the Academy Awards and
some history was made there are the
Academy Awards were last night and then
two of the biggest awards two of the
very biggest went to Mexican director
Guillermo del Toro very cool yeah I'm
just
so I'm guessing President Trump did not
win his Oscar pool that's it
some Republicans some Republicans are
really angry about a joke made it last
night's Oscars about Mike Pence angry
about it yeah my advice those
Republicans don't watch the Tonys the go
well this weekend this is in the news
this weekend the president of China
basically declared himself president for
life now in a related story President
Trump was declared president for what
seems like a lifetime what he got
let's back that up for just a second
when I get this set up to that joke I
said president trying to clear self
president for life a lot of people went
hey I'm gonna do that with my book club
yeah that's weird it was a weird wolf or
tyranny from the conan people and the
big story of course is Pizza Hut
today Pizza Hut introduced a pair of
athletic shoes that have a button that
orders pizza yeah yeah when they heard
about it fans of Pizza Hut said what our
athletic shoes
for that matter where are my feet oh
please please know people are like Oh
pizzas not high in carbohydrates
you